wonderful baked cheesecake for me
food always has to be impressive but
when it comes to desserts
often you see spun sugar or wild
decorations remember simple
is always the most impressive this
cheesecake is so straightforward yet so
delicious
now cream cheese leave it out the fridge
for five or ten minutes go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is the new york
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time i do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake rich delicious but
so simple
work the bowl
lift the bowl to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
nice and creamy now
get your eggs
add the eggs to the mixture bit by bit
doing it this way it's more efficient
hey you're incorporating a lot of air
b the mixture doesn't separate
lastly your egg
lovely
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym i can just make a
cheesecake a day
a cheesecake a day
keep the bingo wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk
stop something going lumpy
now i want to scent that cheesecake
i've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there i want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through
be careful to crush them
then grease the cake in with butter this
will ensure your cheesecake slides out
beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
the mixture hits the bottom of the cake
tin the raspberries rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all these
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture in the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
slightly souffled up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color i wanted
on top
and look at it it's one of the simplest
yet the most stylish cheesecakes
anywhere
beautiful
[Music]
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green fix because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious
lay your figs out in rows take some
rosemary and just peel
that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors
trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp point bring your three figs
together
and just thread
the top of each fig
nice and gently
rosemary works wonderfully with sweet
dishes as the figs roast in the oven the
stalk will impart a lovely subtle flavor
useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of balsamic
vinegar
leave them to sit there for five minutes
and they sort of marinate i know it
sounds odd to use vinegar in your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste i'm gonna
make a really nice caramel four or five
tablespoons of sugar
now flatten that out and get it nice and
even
when the sugar is even caramel cooks
evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in
the one thing you don't do
is shake the pan rapidly
and see it almost like sort of
a lake defrosting and it's hitting to
the center
bubbling still not dark enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas knob of butter in
there
just gently
whisk in the butter is cooling the
caramel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe lay
next add a log of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful
got that nice dark richness
of the caramel a little touch of water
in there
that way the caramel doesn't go too
thick
now put the caramel back on the heat
take your figs and sort of place them in
gently
lovely
and then just add all that lovely little
marinade
mmm don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
no
icing sugar and balsamic vinegar
there's something so tasty
baste
those figs
because the
skin
gets nice and crispy on the outside
and the fig sort of just absorbs the
caramel
delicious
so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
the smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that caramel
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese
the freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
i'm gonna finish that now
with some
zest
and then
some little nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy jam texture of the
fig
with the ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
raspberry milfoy
desserts should always have that wow
factor and this dish is incredibly
simple to prepare but
it tastes and looks absolutely stunning
first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous for pastry
now a non-stick
baking tray
and just lay
the puff pastry on the tray
i want to get the top of the puff pastry
caramelised so we're going to dust it in
icing sugar
now milfoy means
a thousand layers
just lightly dust the top of the puff
pastry with icing sugar
we're gonna start off in a hot oven
at 220
for the first six or seven minutes and
then 10 minutes
at 190
into the oven
now for the filling
fresh vanilla
cream in
and start whisking
want the cream
whisk nice and thick
but look
got all that nice fresh vanilla seeds in
there
next
a nice scraping of orange zest
orange liqueur
don't whisk that in
fold it in
and that stops the cream from separating
lovely
now
take that out of the bowl
and put it into a piping bag unwrap over
your hands
in a way that you're creating this
little pocket
snip off the end
nozzle
in
load up
your bag
just
twist slowly
there's no air
the bag
is nice and full
and firm
nice
chill your gorgeous vanilla and orange
cream in the fridge until you're ready
to pipe it
wow
that
is beautiful there's the layers there
that's the the milfoil pub gently lifted
up
onto the board
we'll slide into three
serrated edge knife
be useful
start deciding on how you're going to
layer it
that bit there that's nice and firm
for my base
that's nice and
decorative for the top and that bit
there for the middle
take out your cream
and put a little touch of cream there
and that just sticks that down
stops it from sliding
pipe
very carefully
a nice thin layer of cream around the
outside
and come back into the middle
beautiful
now
the raspberries
sit them
two by two
now this layer
you'll turn it upside down and put the
caramelized part of the pastry on top of
the raspberries
every time i get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box
again cream
squeeze
from the back of the bag
so you got control
the raspberries
by
2x2
i just want to put another layer of
cream on top
those raspberries because i want some
height with my final layer
i just want to dive in there
put the lid on it
and push that down
there you have
a beautiful stunning
simple
milfoil
dessert to die for
and like all the dishes in my ultimate
cookery course i guarantee it will taste
as sensational as it looks
[Music]
you